a screenwriter on occasion I've learned
that adapting the screenplay is based on
material from another medium written by
another person's a challenging task you
keep wondering as you do it what the
original author is going to think about
your work of course from the original
author is also the same one who's doing
the adoption that can really drive you
crazy because you start wondering what
you're going to think of yourself here
to untangle this predicament are Angie
Dickinson the own and the only one and
only prize-winning / litzer playwright
ever to be nominated as Best Supporting
Actor Jason
or the Best Screenplay based on material
from another medium the nominees are
William Peter Blatty for the Exorcist
Robert Towne for the last detail
James Bridges for the Paper Chase Alvin
Sargent for Paper Moon Waldo salt and
norman Wexler for Serpico and may we
have the envelope please for you Jason
okay the winner is William Peter Blatty
for the eggs
I would like to thank mr. William bloom
who taught me the rudiments and the
craft of screenwriting
and Billy Friedkin and my late parents
who came to this country on a cattle
boat and whose loved and whose courage
have brought me to this moment and to
this place you've honored them tonight
and I thank you very